the games are about to begin and i think
that we know what to
expect more or less from hutch very
solid player and because nate hill is
newer
that could potentially be a problem for
hutch if he finds an opening he doesn't
know like when yasuo played the dutch
against them
i i also would say even the game against
xqc actually it was an opening where xcc
was hanging on
for the first about 20 moves of the game
and hud should not get much of an
advantage so i think
i think it it is possible that will
happen but we're going to see
we're going to see right away so i think
the game started right it has and i have
three knight f6 not something you see
uh in these podcasts very often starting
with a knight out on the first move
right so d4 e6 c4 so i assume nate's
gonna play bishop b4 check here or
pawn to b6
did you have any oh i just watched him
watch them
well i showed him how to play in the
nimzo but basically the point was the
ideas or
sort of the combinations go together so
he plays b6 very nice i like what need
is doing
so do you like this yeah he's taking
away any sort of possibilities for white
to play e4
very easily because knight on f6 and the
bishop will team up so hikaru
how deep did you go in this opening with
him um
yeah so so not super deep i mean i just
told him the basic setup that he should
play for i think already he's probably
out of the preparations i don't think i
showed the queen's queen's indian
defense here but uh as long as he
develops a bishop gets the king out of
center
uh i think i think he'll he'll have a
shot okay he goes g6 maybe not the best
move but i don't dislike it
uh in fact one of our good friends i
think has played the system with black a
few times uh
over the over the board chest too yeah
it's
it seems like a little bit i was
referring to lenderman by the way i
think he's done this a few times yes he
has
and a very strong player of course and
let's listen into nate to hear his
thoughts and what is probably an
unfamiliar position to him
if we're doing like a cool developing
style right so now i lost that pin
right so that's interesting
there's castle
let's see here's this that's nothing
here's this nothing he has this
nothing wait this is nothing that's
nothing
he has this nothing
actually is that something that's a
that's something
it's not it's not a good something but
it's something i don't know what he has
he probably just moves a pawn somewhere
that i don't know about i'll probably d6
though
okay he rooks here i do the same
he's got this triple stack
and i bring the horsey here and then
we're pretty much out of the opening
which is good so it hasn't been he knows
he's out of the opening
he understands that much and i sort of
like how he's reacted i know white is
objectively better
but he's put all of his pieces on pretty
normal squares he has these pawns on d6
and e6
and a player like hutch is looking for a
way to take advantage of the extra space
in a concrete way
but what do you make of this uh from you
know this position
when we just left the opening here yeah
so i mean this i like the opening so far
from nate hill i think this
ah no i was hoping you'd play h6 i
yeah yeah i was worried about this i was
worried that he wouldn't see h6
oh what's interesting though is he
actually mentioned h6 before he was like
oh the bishop could come to g5 but i can
just kick it
and then i guess he just sort of forgot
about his plan to kick it and now
the knight can't move or lose the queen
and the pawn is attacking this knight on
f6
losing a piece yeah this is yeah
kind of rough kind of rough for nate um
i mean hutch of course is playing very
classically good moves
bishop g5 actually probably was not the
best move as i think as i think you know
as well robert because h6 and then
the bishop would have to capture retreat
and then black is two bishops but
nonetheless very very like sort of
classical approach from hudge and
unfortunately for nate he didn't
uh he didn't see this idea was pawn to
e5 which really i think kind of
ends the game sort of on the spot
unfortunately i think there's
one hope for nate and that's if he plays
d takes e5
d takes e5 and actually doesn't even
work which is a little sad
you like play some kind of knight takes
e5 oh right and then yeah and you hope
for the queen trade but
in this particular position it doesn't
work because you take on f3 with check
hitting the king and then after bishop
takes when you retake the queen on d8
you lose this bishop on b7 so sadly
tactics here
don't even work out right exactly yeah
yeah this is very true
so how um yeah and i mean i think i i
think for nate it's just it's it's a
tough spot to be in because again
i i don't know if he got any lessons or
not but it's very hard to prepare for
all these different setups and what
what hutch has done playing this uh this
queen's indian like this is not
something that i think most players
would
would be able to prepare let alone know
it so very very difficult uh very
difficult for nate
definitely because you know when you see
these d4 systems
throughout this tournament everyone was
playing the london system
and then somebody throws this fiance
bishop at you're like wait
what has changed and he went for still a
pretty solid setup with his pawns on d6
and e6 and all that
but the dynamic has changed a lot and
well he unfortunately missed
the fact that his knight has been pinned
on f6 right right i mean again this is
something that's just very classical i i
again if i saw this without looking at
the player's names i'd be like
okay this guy with white is obviously
somebody who's played a lot of chess
they know to take the center and develop
their pieces
um and and so it's just it's showing how
much hutch has uh hutches
has played in the past for sure
and oh but he took the queen oh but he
took first nate could have tried to take
the knight on f3
yeah he seemed like he almost said he
did pre-move rook takes the queen
so right he took .1 seconds he was
not even looking for the knight take but
it wouldn't have worked out but he could
have tried it you're right
yeah almost almost and
now it's a clean extra piece for just
one pawn
and i think hutch in particular is
perfectly
well versed in converting a position
like this i don't think he's in any risk
of messing this up
yeah i think the best chance for nate
here is to trade the bishops and then
push the pawn to h6 again to try and
break the pin
uh it's very important that he does that
i think he i think need
has seen the bishop on b7 like he's used
to this bishop on the diagonal so i
think he'll probably see
that he has to trade the bishops here um
but
it's certainly an uphill battle that's
for sure
and well let's uh listen to nate once
more to see if he
can figure out how to proceed here
because it will be difficult but we
should hear his thoughts
but there isn't guess that
i don't see it guys i'm just gonna do it
so i don't run out of time
in addition to the classical music
kokaru it's cool to see how hard he's
working at the board right now
yeah he's he's definitely trying to find
good moves um
i i do i do like what he's doing even
though rook d4 is not the best move so
he did this
like a triple one weird thing i don't
think i've seen that
i think i have i just didn't defend
against it in time
but he recognizes his mistakes too he's
at the level
yeah he's definitely you can tell that
he's seeing some of these things
um but but unfortunately i mean it's
just he's playing at someone who's a
little bit too strong
um and that's why he's suffering whereas
i think if he's playing at some point
perhaps a little bit weaker and it was a
more balanced matchup
you would see him with very good chance
however here i am still not sure
uh if hutch will find the best moves
because it's not actually so simple you
can't just move the knight because then
you'll lose this pawn um
so it's it's still maybe another mover
hutch has to find another couple of
moves in order to win the game cleanly
or else there might be some chances
yeah that's a great question he won yeah
just
he realizes the knight is doing well as
you were saying protecting the pawn so
let's just trade off
the rooks and if he can trade them all
off because black would love to take the
open file
and i guess nate just says you can have
it but the rooks olive would have come
off
had he tried to keep it right yeah it's
just
tough tough tough position for nate in
this first game but it's still only it's
still only one night for one pawn so
it's not
it is losing but it's not something
where if hutch makes a mistake
nate can't come back from it so one
mistake by hutch
and and it's again it's game on again
and something that's worth pointing out
as well and this is maybe a little bit
more advanced is that in certain end
games let's say you have
a rook and a minor piece and the other
side has one rook
there are many times where the side down
that piece and if you're only down at
night
with you you both have a rook on the
board you can make a draw despite the
material deficit so that's
an outside possibility here definitely
yeah
yeah so maybe something will happen
although hutch takes the bishop takes
the knight which i really don't like
um right that just gives black the whole
diagonal and that's a strong bishop for
for nate hill now yeah i mean f4 is if
hutch plays out four he's he's probably
cleanly winning but again i don't feel
like it's the most
oh my oh
i am also impressed you know i i was not
expecting him honestly to play f4
but there he goes yeah this is this is
this pretty
this is pretty rough actually this is
very rough
um yeah this
i don't i mean i really don't know what
to say hutch is just playing
playing great moves honestly that's all
you can say uh a lot of credit to hutch
because
clearly he's putting a lot of work and
time into the game of chess and it
really is showing
the moves he's playing in this game
taking the center with rookie one e4
uh playing with f4 move just yeah very
very very good stuff from hunch and i'm
was just thinking why did he play f4
first and i think that he has
this concept when his bishop was on g5
still but if he plays f4
his bishop starts running out of squares
so he's probably just think about some
kind of h6
so i think he had this all planned out
and
now nate does the right thing trying to
draw some kind of counter play
on the queen side but right you know
hutch
probably doesn't want to take twice on
b5 as then this rook
ends up on a2 so always look at how
trades affect you
and if the a6 pawn is gone the a2 pawn
is under attack
right exactly yeah so i mean i like that
nate hill found b5
um so we'll see okay hudge takes okay
and then what a move so we're actually
going to tune in to hutch right now to
hear his thoughts but
he's making really clean work of this
okay at least hutch doesn't find 97
[Laughter]
yep he saw it just after what a natural
and good move though 94
that was not the most center but when
you have a fourth of course
the music makes it particularly epic all
right exactly yeah
not the move i got it down to the second
time that's a good move
isn't this kind of a scenario like i was
talking about blood if you trade two
don't blunder yourself only in one piece
there is some danger
yeah if you trade down to too many
pieces there is some danger of maybe
uh maybe some sort of drawing
possibility so i don't really like
knight takes bishop
if hudson played rook d7 i would have
been ready to like to uh to inspect his
uh his microphone or something because
he's been playing
like he's been playing an exceptional
game so far really exceptional but
he traded on e7 so he's so much better
um
but at least now for nate with only one
rook on the board
um with only one work on the board it
becomes a lot easier to find moves as
well i think
um like you know you wanted to put a
rook on the open file
do you think hutch okay plays rook ba do
you think he knows this g4
g5 knight to f6 type of mating net um
probably he
he should have a pretty good idea about
it i'm guessing although i think
probably here he's going to be focused
on trying to win the queenside ponds
would be my guess yeah he goes rook b6
which is a good move
yeah it's it's pretty annoying for nate
hill that his rook cannot get active
like if this rook could spring free and
rook c7
is a good move protecting the pawn but
his rook could somehow like a rook d7
into d2 with a check to win this b2 pawn
he'll have an outside shot here but he's
very passive and that's not how you
want to see your pieces be right exactly
so i mean
this is just i i think knight c5 and b4
is pro
oh my god
[Laughter]
geez he you know he wants he wants to
send a message not just
to you know his opponent in this match
but i think he he may be a little upset
that
everyone thinks the boy boy is the
favorite yeah this is
i mean this is wow this is just class
this this is just class i mean i
yeah i don't know what to say nate has
actually played quite well by the way
other than making the one mistake
i mean that's literally the only mistake
he made was that that pin that's the
only mistake he's made
but man hutch is just yeah hutch is
playing incredible chess
i kind of get the feeling hutch is going
to bring his king in now like a
true like yeah this is like some kind of
like it's like just so
yeah it's just oh man look at this
training well
at least he played this order if he
could have played the other order made
the check and then rook b7 so you could
take the pawn
but this order is also uh very very
clean here yeah i mean just
wow yeah yeah hutch is showing i mean i
think hodges clearly demonstrating why
he's one of the favorites in the
tournament
um because he's just yeah almost every
movie he's played has been
been very very good maybe not the
absolute perfect move but it's been more
than good enough
and um and it's just been a very
impressive display in this game
of hutches hutch's uh chess skills and a
great reaction by nate hill not to trade
the rooks because
in this position the knight would then
scoop up the remaining pawns yeah but
yeah 97 she's in 95. is he he's going to
go 90
wow i mean just props to
that's that's all i can say yeah no i
mean it's just i i
i more than anything i just feel bad for
me because he actually has not played a
bad game he walks in the checkmate
i mean he has not played a bad game he's
just playing someone who's just uh
i mean just much much stronger than him
honestly like
he's not really done much wrong he
really hasn't i mean he allowed one pin
but but unfortunately like hutch is just
uh he's one of the favorites and he's
he's clearly showing why i mean just
i there's like i i can't even really
criticize any of hutch's moves in that
game
the opening playing rookie one and e4
like that's what a grand master would
play
playing bishop g5 maybe that's the only
move that wasn't perfect
but that's literally the only move in
the game that i could criticize from
hutch
everything else i mean rookie rookie one
is what grand masters play uh this is
the best moment black has to go 94 if we
discuss
opening theory so um this is a
well-known variation but black has to
play knight e4 so white gets e4 white's
better so
um just yeah really really impressive
impressive game from hutch
the most impressive game i think from
start to finish that i've seen
uh thus far in the event i have to
completely agree i mean every single
move
with the one exception being bishop g5
because h6
would have been a reasonable response
but even bishop g5 was by no means a bad
move i know neither of us were saying
that
but it just maybe didn't work out as
well shouldn't have worked out the way
it did
and nate hill sort of he didn't play the
move h6 which i
we heard him say that if oh bishop g5
not a big deal i'll play h6
and then he didn't play it when he had
the chance and well we're already off in
the second game now
with uh nate hill taking the white
pieces
and nate is prob wait what
oh game got a board okay so they have to
just do the rematch okay
okay but knight f3 is nate taking
lessons from hutch
[Laughter]
playing the mirror yeah i expect i
expect nate to play the london system
um
uh okay
so d4 bishop f4 okay plus e3
okay slightly different opening set up
by by nate here
who's been teaching him let's listen to
nate and hear his thoughts about this
position because
i don't know who his coach has
he wants to bring to the middle right so
i want to stop that early
i think that was too early for that yeah
shoot
i think i'm supposed to be over here
already it's fine
we'll figure it out
i've never seen the reity open
not familiar
okay so now my oh i do have this stuff
car i feel like i'm watching one of your
blisters
[Laughter]
yeah exactly yeah
he was watching video view right before
the match so you're his inspiration
yeah i i definitely didn't i haven't i
haven't other than coaching
before his game against eve rob i
haven't given any other coaching
then i have to push h and then that
that's fine you only need one nest right
awesome he calls it the nest okay so
they're actually playing the same game
but with the pieces to say
colors reversed yeah and i mean he
he clearly gets this position the way he
was talking about it
he understands it but he didn't know the
name of the opening and
it's so he's probably pretty new to it
but still i i really wonder
what got him into this open we'll have
to ask him but it's a good one it's a
very solid one and as i said
yeah i think maybe he's just you know
what i'm thinking is maybe he's uh
seeing the mirror because he's he plays
this with black
so maybe he's just seeing the mirror and
he tried to play the same opening setup
as before because
the only other thing that i would say is
like if like if i had coached him or
something i could see this opening but i
didn't coach him so
um so i i think the only real
explanation is that it's a mirror that's
the only thing i can think of
that makes sense and you do have plenty
of videos out there of you playing this
exact opening i'm sure so
it's maybe he was watching but they're
they're they're playing the same opening
basically with colors reversed now
that's true he did the same thing right
the uh bishop g2
castle the same exact position as the
first game with next
right and
i wonder if hutch has realized that too
though now
it's a great question it is hard for
some people to think about
the position from the other side but it
is the same exact game
with one extra tempo because now
nathal's white and he hit the first move
right exactly yeah so i mean i i i don't
think we're gonna see the same mistake
though
right but but we'll see we'll see uh
someone says of course he realizes yeah
i
i've seen like hutch because he is such
a he's played so much chess
he probably does realize that it's the
same opening setup um
but this is gonna be this is gonna be
fun to see what hutch does in terms of
the setup
and jim super jim hutch who is just
played
a masterpiece in that first game he is
now up
by a minute and a half so nate hill
despite
choosing the opening playing a line that
resembles the first game
he is now thinking then he does fee
encounter the bishop right yeah
i like i like what nate has done the
opening phase of the game um
okay now is he gonna play h3 here it
doesn't even matter when he does it but
but i do want to see i do want to see uh
h3 being played at some point by by nate
and that way he can avoid any future e5
e4 we saw him
lose to that exact tactic in the first
game it doesn't work so well
because the bishop's on b2 stopping e5
but h3 is a very important move and one
that i think he should play right away
so he doesn't have to like bog himself
down later
worrying about it right i would agree
with that yeah
and actually this is a great example of
did he have a learning moment
because they say you either win or you
learn and well now that knight c6 is
played
e5 is incoming and there it is very nice
very nice from nate i like this yeah
very very nice move
and just for everybody watching once you
fianchetto your bishop
it means your bishop can't really
retreat because once the bishop
goes to d7 it can't go to h5 because the
pawn on g6
actually blocks its progress so you can
play this move g4 and the bishop is
trapped
exactly yeah no this is this is a great
opening so far from uh from uh from nate
i like what he's doing
and here he's probably gonna play d3 i
assume uh or d4 my concern with d3 is
that maybe hutch will go queen to c8
i hope he doesn't do it that'd be really
nasty queen to see it might already be
really good for black yep putting that
pressure on the
pawn on h3 and then the king would have
to go out to h2 to defend it but he but
then you had knight before
oh you're the devil hicarus let's show
that and he still has it's a quincy
yeah he still has it hopefully he
doesn't see it but
because these bishops are staring each
other down so you should always think
of the way to get your piece out of the
way and
let's listen to hutch to see maybe if
he's thinking about this exact plan
all right so if you push his pawn
i could just push this pawn here and
then wait for him to capture and then
grab a hold of that file he's got a weak
pawn here right so
if i for example move my queen there i
can put some pressure on that pawn
oh no wow i do have a lead in
development he still hasn't developed
this night
if i were him i'd probably think about
doing that
but it's not like
you know he's playing fine so far i
think right
i'm looking at pushing this pawn
also queen here is like an interesting
talk maybe with the idea of like yeah
yeah i know he's definitely played quite
a bit yeah it's
this is a very tough matchup i think for
uh in in in general for um
for uh for nate certainly but he plays
e4 which i really like this is a good
move he's playing in the center of the
board
um and the good thing here i think is
that now hutch won't be able to get this
idea of queen c8 because there always be
a pawn push
to attack the knight on f6 so
fortunately hutch is gonna have to
probably i actually don't know what hut
should do here it's not
taking the pawn and playing e5 does not
really feel very natural uh it's
probably the best way to play as a human
but objectively uh neat is doing quite
well here after the pawn push
yeah it's a very good decision and we
heard hutch talking maybe but
i could play e6 and then allow nate to
capture me on d5
and so he's waiting for the pantry as i
want to release the tension but
he also mentioned this queen seat idea
and as we're saying e6 blocks that
entire
option so the bishop nd7 looks bad if
you play e6 and that's what makes it
hard to play
yeah so um i mean but i'm very happy
with the way nate has played because
he's playing something that he doesn't
understand
he i mean like he's seen some of these
setups but he's not super familiar with
them so the way that he's playing this
opening has been
fantastic and um i really want to see
how hutch responds this because i think
certainly if hutch has a bad reaction to
the setup
um what would happen is that uh is that
basically it's something that i think
his opponents might pray for now hudge
plays queen c8 which is actually a very
bad move here
because white can push the pawn to
attack tonight come on nate neat
just do it oh that was you robert that's
me who made e5
that's me i'm just showing you an idea
shame on you stop getting my hopes up
i'm sorry i blundered queen sometimes i
have to make good moves as well
so e5 would be a very good move the
knight on f6
doesn't have many squares to go to in
fact it has one safe square on h5
and you know what they say about knights
in the rim knights on the rim are grim
yes and you usually they call them dim
but i like to think of them as grim and
then people get mad at me because
they're like oh grim is a good thing
sometimes
you see the grim reaper like that's
doesn't seem good
right exactly yeah come on nate just do
it come on nate come on e5
would you think that it's an easy move
to find no i mean i think the thing
that's hard is probably
he's probably not used to diagonal so he
probably doesn't realize the pawn on
each for his hanging
wait was that me um no that he did it
yes come on nate come on let's
let's listen to him i thought that was
me accidentally making the move but
listen but i just wanted to do something
very nice
he's extremely quiet there's no way he
takes it
hold on let's think
i'll get my horse out i gotta get my
knight at my rook out
yeah that's obviously what he's gonna do
it's annoying but let's see is he forced
is there any way i can force him to do
something
just develop
he doesn't see that pawn each was
hanging it's still okay though i think
even if he gives up the pawn i think
he's still doing okay because what he's
got to play is just
keep that knight on i see a force in two
that i could get him into right then
it might not be good yeah but he sees g4
as an option for him
right so even though queenie two is a
blunder i think even though it's a
blunder it's a good move
he sees the idea of g4 to trap the
knight so um
obviously he misses the pond but i like
i like the reasoning and what he's
trying to come up with so
in general i think it's uh it's it's
very good i i'm very pleased with what
i'm saying
out of nate in both of these games
honestly like he's he's a big underdog
but um but the reason that behind his
moves has been very very fundamentally
sound
for sure and you know he has like all
the right ideas down
just sometimes he gets a bit of tunnel
vision as we all do where
we forget that wait not only is this
knight potentially trapped but wait that
queen and bishop
were attacking this pawn so he has a
really good grasp he actually
understands the position quite well
and i'm with you a card this position is
far from over it is one pawn
and it's important well the funny thing
i was going to say is it's it's in a way
it's a good thing he blundered the ponks
if he had played pawn to g4 allowing
knight f4 he wouldn't be down any
material
but i think he would actually be losing
almost for sure so in a way it's a good
thing that he that he blundered this
pawn because now he'll never have
this pawn pushing chief or after which
he would be very close to loss
it's a great point that in terms of ease
of playing he plays king h2 now so
if you played that one move earlier that
would have been preferred
but now if you take on g2 and the king
takes i get the open h file for my rook
so it's not all bad for white
yeah i mean this the game is still very
much alive for white with this knight on
on the edge of the board
i think the main issue for nate here is
trying to develop the knight and the
rook into the game that's the
main problem but again it's still only
one pawn
and against somebody like hutch who's
one of the one of the best players in
the field to only be down one pawn to be
hanging in there the way that nate has i
think this is it's
it's great it's great to see agreed
completely and one thing
i would say in addition all that is that
from hutch's point of view
he knows he's the favorite but he also
knows that his knight h5
isn't comfortable but sometimes you play
a move like f6 or
trying to desperately free up that
knight and those kind of moves can
backfire while it does help the knight
it exposes your king a bit more so you
have to be very careful before ever
pushing this f-pawn because then your
king on jake at least
will feel a little bit of heat right
exactly so i i think i mean i i think
this
nate's done a great job queen five is a
fantastic move from
from hutch here uh and now really the
only one that i think probably keeps
nate in the game is probably something
like knight to a3
but it's a very hard move to play you
put the knight on the edge of the board
i think most players have been told not
to do that they've been told you want to
bring the knights towards the center so
i think uh
okay queenie two is not a bad move
either actually it's not bad at all
i kind of like this move um as well this
is good yeah he protects this pawn e5
another time
so that he can actually develop the
knights of c3 now right
exactly yeah so i i like i like what
nate has done again both games first
game one mistake the bishop for the pawn
but here like
one small mistake and it's only one pawn
and probably against hutch it's going to
be too much
um but it's great to see considering how
strong with player hutch is
yeah and hutch has to find these good
moves which he hasn't finally queen to
f5
but it's not such an easy position for
him either because there are no
more clear targets to exploit so you'll
have to actually come up with a plan
rather than just like piling up pressure
on a single piece right exactly and
again this is where it's going to be
very hard for nate
starting to get a little bit low on time
he's got to find a way to bring
guess he's got to find a way to bring
the knight unfortunately yeah this is
the natural looking square but it
blunders upon on c2
um although i guess it's he's still in
the game because with this knight still
stuck on h5
um uh okay now he goes knight h5 okay or
queen g4 rather okay okay come on nate
queen e4 let's see
queen e4 would be an excellent move yeah
i mean it's very hard
i mean if need sees queen e4 i'll i'll
be really really inspired
i'll be very inspired and
i'm guessing that let's listen into nate
because i'm guessing he sees
that knight f4 check is a threat but
let's make sure that he
comes up with a good response i can do
this
yeah very tough damn
what could i've done better there i
think the team is queen
instead of the horse yeah i mean it's
very hard obviously it's pretty new to
the game
it's not awesome obvious idea but yeah
very tough unlucky
and he just said it he just said queen
on e4 he recognized his mistake
and hutch is probably gonna see the
checkmate in two as well
yeah i expect touch to see the checkmate
yeah queen h3 check the king only has
one move
and then there he finds it
see that's the thing as we're talking
about playing hutch is so difficult
because even when you're playing really
well when hutch plays his best he just
has that experience
and he doesn't blunder very often right
and that's very true yeah hutch is just
like
yeah really i mean what what what can
you say
what can you say i mean very very well
played by hutch and actually i mean
honestly in terms of nate
i i have to say even though nate nate
loses this match this has been very
impressive on his end as well i mean
really the the difference in in both
these games has been one blunder like
and in this game it was a small blunder
before the before the knight of four
pins so
um i think need has definitely
definitely met
my expectations in in this match for
sure
i think for me he's exceeded them
because
you know you're right just one little
blunder and it just goes to show that
nate's progress is very legitimate where
and it also goes to show
what the next step will look like where
these little mistakes
against some players that were just
starting or newer to the game
they may not be devastating but against
hutch you just there's no coming back
from it and there's a resignation
so hutch wins the match right exactly
yeah
yeah and i mean just also
let's go back to this game a little bit
because we liked how
nate played early on his decision to
kick this bishop away
from g4 with h3 was smart and
i think icarly understood that the
bishop couldn't belong here
but at the same time he maybe didn't
know how to meet this kind of queen c8
and eventual attack on them yeah i mean
it's again those is pretty
far into the middle game and i think
it's just a matter of playing against
someone who's i mean just just had a lot
of experience in chess but the fact that
he found pawn to e5 i was very pleased
by
i mean one pawn that king h2 move uh
really costs in the game although he had
that chance later with with uh
with queen to e4 as well so i mean i'm
i'm very proud of the way nate played
today in both these games
um i mean this is this is he's playing
against someone who is at least 500
points higher rated than him who's
probably had several years at least
several years more worth of experience
and the fact that he was able to hang in
there for as long as he did
and um and really i mean just it came
down to basically two mistakes
by nate i mean he should be very very
pleased with the way he played because
it was it was fantastic to see
for sure and and also that he recognized
his mistakes in this game he played h3
in the first game he didn't
find that move to kick the bishop right
and then after he played 94 he lost
queens oh maybe i showed my queen there
but
we are going to take a quick break and
when we return we will have hutch and
nate hill
and talk to them about their match and
hear their thoughts so stay tuned
everybody we'll be right back
with the chess.com pop jams well we
welcome both
hutch and nate hill here guys hey cara
and i were super impressed with how you
two played so
well done thank you appreciate it
appreciate it
and nate let's start with you because
you were playing some
newer openings were you working hard on
them were you getting some coaching like
how did you come up with these ideas
so the one that i was playing was
actually hikaru's from
uh the game against erob which was a wee
week or so ago
unfortunately i haven't had much time to
practice for hutch because there's been
a lot of fortnite stuff going on
recently so i was told to kind of just
try to fall back on that
because i think what did you start with
what's what was your opening on i played
knight f3 just to throw you off because
i figured he cairo prepared you for d4
yeah i was thinking it was gonna be d4
so i just kind of just went with what i
knew was going to be
put me in an okay spot i ended up kind
of transposing into
the same kind of structure anyways but
yeah
yeah we're good i have the game uh if
you can see in the in the chat here
um so one this opening was all very good
akara and i were
enjoying this and at this point rookie
won great move
playing e4 d6 was a good response but
you nade and after bishop g5
we heard you talking about how you
should play h6 before you know once the
bishop got here
and then in the game you brought your
knight down so was that just like a snap
reaction and then you
like you know palm like oh gosh i knew i
should have played h6 first
yeah i think so i think i did it the
next game faster too so yeah
i think i just missed that again and i
mean hutch you
played a really clean game hikaru can
speak this but we were
super impressed by your conversion yeah
i was i was
really trying to be careful because i
blunder a lot um
so i i tried to just like sit on my
hands and just like make myself look at
the board for like 10 seconds before i
made any kind of move um
yeah i thought as soon as i got this
pawn push i felt pretty comfortable
yeah i felt pretty uncomfortable as soon
as you put the pawn there
yeah i don't think i've seen it like
three in the same line
like that much oh man i like to push all
five pawns
c d f and g i like to go nuts with it
but i was hoping you'd let me do it but
you played you fee and cut out the
bishop and
couldn't do that all right yeah so i i
was kind of curious
um so so this first game obviously
for you nate it was really one mistake
cost you the game and i think
uh in most other situations or against
most other players in this event if
you probably would have gotten away with
it but because hutch was so strong i
mean this one mistake
was too much but you really made very
few blunders throughout both games
um and i was wondering like is it you
what was your thought process throughout
just try to avoid like you know making a
bad move to your night or was just
just general general thoughts it was
basic it was just
the basic openings that we talked about
and honestly like
just taking my time and making sure
calculating all the pieces right
and that's that was pretty much what i
focused on just trying to get my
calculations right and every time i had
a lead in the in a calculation hutch did
something that
i just didn't see coming or it just like
i'd offer
a trade-up he just would never take it i
think he did that three times
so it was just well played by him and if
we go to the second game because this
game was decided with this one move e5
and once hutch went up the knight it was
his game to win but the second game
i mean this was also really well done by
both of you first of all the question
that
carl and i were wondering was did you
guys realize it was the same exact
opening but with reverse colors yeah
oh yeah yeah for sure okay because
sometimes people just don't recognize
that like
what they just did and because you're
playing with different colors you just
forget that
last game but it's good that you had
that and first you nate
you saw that this bishop should be
kicked out and you learned your lesson
and played h3
exactly i was hoping you'd let me get
away with it again but i figured
[Laughter]
on white pieces it was it was a little
easier to see i guess yeah
but i also kind of wanted you to push
that pawn because i knew that it would
make that h3 pawn
a target at some point and i ended up
moving my queen to c8 and
doubling up on that so actually i was
going to add one thing robert if you if
you stop after bishop d7
so i was wondering if you realize hutch
that after pawn to d3 here
you could have gone queen to c8 right
away
yeah i i was thinking about it i can't
remember what move i played
before i did that um well basically what
you did is you allowed nate to get his
pawn rolling so pawn was on e4 when you
played queen c8
because if you go queen c8 right here
white is already i think close to losing
so if i go king it should unite you for
okay which i think you got to that point
later
wait why explain why that's good because
you when i take the knight you take the
bishop on b2
yeah i was looking at that move i think
i got two into my head sometimes i play
a little overly cautious
wouldn't i take the bishop there hicario
what's that you have to take your kings
attack your king and then i take the
bishop and then your rook next oh yeah
that's that's huge
yeah it's a really good i'm sorry guys
go ahead robert
it's a really good lesson that when
pieces are on the same diagonal these
bishops or if your rooks
are on the same line that if you can get
the piece out of the way and with a
check
that way it has to be dealt with then
the other
bishop that you're attacking now becomes
yours yeah that's huge
so like if you go forward in the game
like hutch did this a few moves later
but you actually responded very
very well to this you played e4 and like
here when he played queen state
it's the same thing if you move the king
up to protect the pawn there's the same
knight check
right uh and so you played e5 which was
a fantastic move
and then hutch played night knights at
h5 and here actually if you'd gone king
to h2 protecting this pawn now
you would have been probably quite a bit
better because this knight is very
uncomfortable
on on the edge of the board yeah i was
worried about getting trapped
that's i was trying to work on it i just
i guess i didn't see that king move
yeah yeah it's a hard one to say did you
see that your pawn h3 was under attack
nate
uh yeah i did um i just started i
started thinking about something else i
forget what i tried to
get your night trap basically that's
what i was going for but i just
i was gonna do it in two moves but you
did the bishop and then kind of screwed
me
right right because like if you go queen
d2 and then you robber you just make a
random move like a6 or something
then pawn to g4 does trap the knight
because your queen covers the one
exactly that's what i was going for but
i think yeah yeah
i was worried about him moving to queen
to d2 because because
i would i would have had to move my
bishop and then move my knight to like a
really unnatural spot on
g7 and that would have just you would
have started cramping my position i
started to get like a little nervous
here but as soon as you let me take the
pawn on h3 i figured i was pretty good
mm-hmm yeah and nate that's why i was
wondering if you saw the pawn hd was
hanging because you had the right
idea like the 100 correct idea but
unfortunately the one reason doesn't
work is really good for hutch and he saw
it
and snagged your pawn so i just want to
get a little bit of tunnel vision so
focused on this knight on h5 and
trapping it
that perhaps you overlook the fact that
this pawn h3 was happening that happens
to all of us
yeah i think that's i think that's about
what happened yeah yeah
and i mean honestly and after that you
came back pretty well
because it was not a clear you lost a
pawn but the game was not over by
anybody it was only down one point but
then i made a huge
stupid mistake with my i saw my horse
over here doing nothing the whole game
sorry night
and i just like i just want to get him
out and do something and
just made a huge mistake on the next
move and as soon as you made him sick we
actually
tuned into uh your stream and you're
like oh i should have put my queen on e4
and actually if you played queen e4
hecarim i mean we thought that white's
position is not bad at all
yeah because even though you're still
behind by one pawn the knight is stuck
on the
stuck on the square on the edge of the
board h5 square and the knight can't
really get back into the game easily and
so it still would have been quite quite
an interesting interesting game if you
had found this move but
but even though you didn't find the move
i thought most most ideas you came up
with in in both games other than the
the very slight blenders you made were
uh it was very impressive and it was it
was great to see because you followed
the basics and and you really did
get your pieces developed and you were
just playing in the middle game and i
mean if you had been playing at someone
perhaps
not quite as strong as your opponent uh
maybe the result would have been
different
um so i thought it was you played very
very well i appreciate it yeah
learned a lot from you guys and hutch on
your end
your conversion in that first game you
know you're up a night for a pawn you
didn't give him
any chances like we thought that maybe
there would be some outside shot
for nate to come back you played pretty
much perfectly and the car and i were
really praising your play
it was very impressive so thank you such
it's such an honor there's not too many
grandmasters in the world so to have a
couple of you guys say that means a lot
appreciate it
for sure well enjoy your stream thank
you so much for taking part in
hutch we'll see you next round nate i
hope you keep playing chess because you
really have improved so much since you
started
for sure man i hope we can do uh more of
these this has been really fun
really appreciate it yeah good games
guys thank you